[Music]
so this is a common Bowl constrictor
very popular in the 90s oh okay all
right good PR in the 90s the boa
constricted you don't hear about the
mushroom anymore yeah wait so this thing
holy [ __ ]
laughs
so this is Astro and he's super sweet
like he's domesticated you're talking
about generations and generations yeah
you could tell right
he is the biggest one so it's scary but
something about his regular pattern
makes me less scared than an all-white
and an all-black interesting it's
interesting how colors Pat is more
familiar to problems
the reason why we're okay with that
pattern is because we've seen it before
because homeless pimp has the exact
pants
yeah that's funny so look at it look at
it it's crawling on his back he doesn't
even give a [ __ ] oh my God he's super
sweet so you know back in the days I'm
reading this book called uh I believe
it's called um forgot the name of it
I'll pull it up but it's about snake the
reptile trade industry you know we
people have this on this this need to
quench this [ __ ] appetite for like
exotic animals these things weren't
captured bad they were smuggling these
things in in the 60s anyway
um so but these have been captive breath
for so long over 40 years that's like a
wolf right when you keep on breeding it
and so you're saying that's the
domesticated he's super sweet I have a
you know he will not ever constrict
around your neck for any reason ever if
he's strong let's look for a good time
the general rule of thumb if you're
handling large snakes this is not by any
means a large it looks pretty big but
there's anything above seven and a half
eight feet you want to have a second
person there because accidents do happen
like what what could be an example of an
accent that could happen just constrict
you like this snake right now if it's
he's strong enough I'll [ __ ] his ass up
but but if it began to constrict you
what would we what would Sal and I have
to do okay there's two things truthfully
we're probably not gonna so vanity
please listen because you either put
alcohol if it has a uh uh a bite and a
grab that's that's bad that's like
showing that's food motivated or it
feels yeah you know who wants to say
something hold on yeah yeah look out
so I just want to give a shout out to
all my people
my Colombians out there
he's like I'm gonna be at the Cleveland
funny bone
so he's not even headshot I could touch
his head yeah what did we do what would
we do yeah what would we do so I when I
got bit uh and like that hooked on I
would just put hash sanitizer alcohol
and they immediately release I was also
told you can uh put your finger in the
anal vent and then that'll make them
feel uncomfortable how big
not me do it more that's a joke
it's like
this is what it was waiting for
I didn't want to squeeze you yeah I know
coach name because my name's Mateo
event that you can fit you can fit your
finger your finger in it I'll show you
and let's let's also show Sergio your
finger
well because I
I mean that thing's not gonna shoot
spray [ __ ] at us is it
I'm like this
up as long as generally a male girls are
shorter and you could you could you
could diddle that anal tail and he's not
gonna get mad
I wouldn't mess with it I've never done
it before that's what I that's the thing
that's right you're telling me that the
instructions from the professionals
it's time to your neck and Sonic you're
running to find the [ __ ] yeah
you want to give it a try give one a try
uh you wanna you have to you want to
hold it
you can
um just lick your pinky and give it a
try
[Music]
I'll touch it I'll touch it yeah so you
don't want to touch it like that that's
like you know you don't want to poke at
it I'm sorry
I didn't beat up drug dealers when I was
16.
oh it doesn't feel bad oh beautiful man
I feel like love it is that just one
muscle is that what that is it's just
one muscle they have a spine and ribs
why does it smell like adobo
does it die no I mean they can anything
before uh the anal vents it'll probably
survive okay yeah
no they don't generate they don't
regenerate their tails like certain
lizards do okay so if you're gonna chop
a snake get above the [ __ ] yeah if
you want to take it
they'll be moving for hours shout out
anal vents shout them all out yeah shout
them all out the anal vent um keep them
clean guys yeah
shout out cutesy names for asses yeah
yeah I found a new name the anal vent
and I'm gonna call my penis the hemipeen
yeah come on give it a shot Chris just
stand up tall for me but I don't wanna
it's a new shirt
he's very cool I will say this I will
say this I don't want to do it at all
if you do it I'll do it
just act as a tree but Sergio be here
yeah hold the mic for me well hold on a
second there
just what are the odds what are the odds
because there are odds that he just
takes a bite of our Goddamn face
50 50.
have you smelled Chris's breath it
smells like a dead rat
oh [ __ ] Chris I I lied I was lying I I
completely lied hey okay I'm okay you're
fine but yeah but he's gonna when he
starts to wrap around you know he's not
gonna wrap around you you let me know
when you're done
what's up guys do you dance
um
I got hey what's up everybody got a
brand new hour go to christycomedy.com
for Ticky Wiki's second show added in
Dublin Belfast London sold out
um Chicago Theater sold out go check
christycomedy.com we're going to
announce New Year's Eve in Long Island
um all my dates at christycounty.com
it's a brand new hour of uh comedy
material
I love animals
oh my God he's fine he's fine look he's
fine he's that close
so a slow flick of the tongue it's just
curiosity test one a short fast one is
very like unsure of itself like what the
[ __ ] is going on is it food is you know
don't [ __ ] some [ __ ] up I'm good
thank you imagine this is my fit
yeah there you go you serving looks we
talk about this I don't serve looks
anymore I just go for complete Comfort
I'm at a I thought it was gonna grab my
eyeball
so I also have I did it I have one more
Snake style you want to try this one
he's Brave girl Oliver Oliver's next
what's what's up Oliver is the next one
what is that Oliver is a Burmese python
the Everglades is an invasive species
what is it what is is it is it more
dangerous than that one none of them are
dangerous let's cut that talk out very
negative
none of them are dangerous see he's cool
all right I'll try it I feel like my job
is not being done here I want to like I
want I want to be having like a steak
party I feel like you're traumatized
that promised me that I promise you that
you're gonna be fine you'll keep that
face away from us and I will I will I
want this to be honestly we're joking
around but I want to be a positive
experience I don't want to freak anybody
already dude will it sense my sweat no
I'll be fine this one it doesn't like
the shampoo I use no it'd be fine okay
yeah he's very tolerant all right all
right so I'm just gonna put him around
the shows I'll hold the head but I might
it's good to do one thing a day that
scares you this is it I know I'm just
telling you right now my heart is
beating out of my chest is it gonna feel
that no it's going to take a blood
pressure meds today I can't go near that
face though okay okay I'll do it take my
blood pressure okay all right can you
hold this for me and put your phone down
how many milligrams are you on
50.
um I I I don't know exactly okay let's
I'll talk we can I just got I just got
put on blood pressure medicine
I I will
this is not good let's talk about our
meds um just stay right right by me
Sergio just stay right by me yeah I'm
gonna be right by you I promise it's
gonna be oh
since the 10 out of 10 scared though
okay I'm scared just watch it I don't
look it in the face I'm scared it would
be gold though if the biggest face I
ain't gonna look at his face I ain't
gonna look at the things all right
look at her face
I'll go over here I'm saying right here
I thought oh okay it's just his ass I
got the head
I got the head
I'm gonna be in Canada October 14th and
15th Hamilton Toronto we ahead of the
show I'm gonna be in Richmond Virginia
and Hershey Pennsylvania in October
in November I'm going to be in
Knoxville Atlanta and Birmingham where
is the [ __ ] where is this
[ __ ] please no you're fine
you're fine I got it I'm very scared
dude
I'm going to be in Louisville and
Evansville and then in December I'm in
Florida and California and Florida I'm
in Tampa we had a second show show I'm
at the hall Hard Rock in Orlando the
Crest Theater in Sacramento uh
Jacksonville what's up I'm there
and see Sacramento San Jose and Santa
Rosa in December everything's on sale
right now on sale volcanocomedy.com
well done well done there you go
feeling like this
I got that I'm swooping around though
exactly no no
his head's looking right at me
wow there's a little is it [ __ ]
because the anal vent is a little dark
black what does its [ __ ] look like
cat [ __ ]
snakes she looks a little bit like Kesha
but that's also like calcified like
urates like the urine so it's like
liquid but it's also like a scientist or
something I don't know we got one more
what do you feel about snakeskin items
hate it I'm indifferent I don't get
offended by it what does that does that
mean the snake died for it or is it just
yeah it's a part of a trade just like
you might get a fur coat yeah yeah but
is that that's not from shed skin no no
that's actual skin okay and there's
usually much larger constrictors like
constrictors like reticulated pythons or
African rocks they go find them to hunt
them to chops yeah you know it's not
wasteful you can eat the meat what do
you think about that have you ever
tasted snake no I had crackers I had an
alligator I believe a frog what do you
think about people eating snake I think
it's fine
let me ask you a question
it's it's the end of days I got the
eating habits of a badger I eat anything
it's the it's the end of the day vaginal
give it would you eat would you would
you resort to eating a human first or a
snake if they're both dead you got a
human and a snake
animal teeth well I don't know what it
seems like you love snakes more than you
love your own family
first
oh god dude so okay so what's this next
name this is Astro he's from Florida he
was delivered by uh FedEx oh there you
go right he was uh five months old and
he's been with the family ship station
promo code hey babe because you got a
great discount how do you name them just
like yeah we were doing like the planets
and stuff I never ran out of planets
okay so okay so let's let's get to
Oliver okay Oliver this is the biggest
one Oliver's the biggest guy let's get
to planet Oliver let's get to planet is
Oliver the biggest guy search
biggest and he has the potential
when did they all eat last
now he doesn't have the lid for this
a couple of weeks Oh I thought they had
to feed like
yeah do they still see daily no so they
have very slow digestive systems so a
snake as they get older you can feed a
snake every three weeks to a month
I've had a snake one time in 1990.
now is that one feeding considered
breakfast lunches yeah that didn't eat
for an entire year really entire year
skinny [ __ ] it's got to be impossible
no how is it how is it okay how is it
storing and then using and distributing
the nutrients from its prey one year
decomposed they barely move
that's why they live so long but but the
thing it ate is certainly decomposing
and losing any value that yeah so I mean
he did lose a little waste it was living
off the fat that he the fat storage but
it never it didn't get it didn't look
malnourished that was the thing that
threw me off like it looked fine a year
it was exactly a year my snake didn't
eat and then one day he decided to eat
it was a ball python they're notorious
for not eating well that day that he
decided to eat look to look out right
and I was keeping these snakes a little
irresponsibly like I had the snake the
ball python with a Burmese python
cohabits you know they were sharing the
same enclosure now you have one snake on
top of the other one's air holes that's
okay
sorry buddy so what would happen
he cares all of a sudden no um so what
happened when you put them two together
that was irresponsible why because they
could fight there's you run the risk of
uh cross-contamination it could stress
the animals out these are solitary
creatures they don't want to be they're
not like freaking geese like you know
walking down the street but what about
when you see like those tons of snakes
all together like that that's usually
mating very few snakes uh live in in
colonies like that very few as soon as
the babies are born they're on their own
no
that's what I think I like about them
because I like to be by myself right
yeah because your family loved you
so snakes are all positive being
abandoned you grow up without a father
no wonder why there's so many snakes in
the bride
all right let's take here's Oliver
oh he's such a beautiful snake oh God I
bet
so generally when you add to a snake
enclosure with bigger snakes this is
called tap training because they don't
know the difference between food and the
person last time the food motivated you
just tapped them like this on the head
and I do that little sound to make a cue
beep beep they don't know I'm sorry they
don't know the difference between food
and you is that what you said when the
cage is first open because a lot of
times
a lot of times you'll find I'm going to
put the mic down so I can put them up in
I'll just demonstrate how I would answer
his enclosure
[Laughter]
here we go
oh my God
this is Oliver he's a hypo Burmese
python he's absolutely beautiful so you
see how uh Pluto is lucistic that's not
I mean very rare would you find that in
the wild surviving like a white yeah so
these are more in the wild yeah so what
they do they'll find one then they they
breed it and they they got all sorts of
colors they got it's like the it's like
the pride flag colors colors yeah and so
the books yeah okay so now we're
stopping the snake's head so they're
gonna snake knows that you're not a rat
right yes right okay so these are very
food motivated you got to be respectful
not everyone is like
uh is is gaming not everyone should have
a Burmese python it's like owning a
Rottweiler you know it's like you know
I've had two yeah so you might be you
might be a cop candidate for all of us
are great but you know what I'm saying
that there are a a a a type of animal
you got to be rubbing its head in this
the snake tongue is is kind of going
crazy right now can you see that pimp
okay so I tapped him so now he
understands what's going on yeah yeah
can you move that snake box let's make
my job hard
and I mean I don't mean it's box or it's
anal vent
another thing is When approaching a
snake you never want to go from above
imagine no why would you do that right
because they're they're Predators right
or they hunted by hawks large birds oh
you're a hawk versus snake right so a
hawk can come down slice that exactly
fly it in the air but have you ever seen
like a hawk because you watch these
videos a hawk around grab a snake stop
to fly away and then the snake will bite
the hawk the hawk goes down and the
snake Falls and the snake beats the hawk
yeah but then everybody they both die
and no one else die from being dropped
is it yeah the snake can die from being
dropped from a high let me tell you
something did we drop one of these
things off the 10th I had uh did this
this is how this is how fascinating
reptiles are I was living in my studio
apartment right I didn't even have a bed
I had but you might be sitting back
there soon because your family has had
enough of this
a mattress against the wall and all my
animals when I first moved into my first
apartment at my time at the time I was
Jaden this Jewish Puerto Rican girl her
name is Kelly Greenberg and she loved
the animals okay Greg Greg Greg is going
to be associated with you
and I had a lizard that I um used to
care for at a head hunting agency when I
worked at Petland this lady who owned
her own head hunting firm said Sergio
would you care for my iguana Iggy and I
said go to the uh the the office clean
the iguana cage make 20 bucks go back
home she gave me the Iguana it was a six
foot iguana
serious and we named I changed the name
I didn't like Iggy I thought I was too
hacky I said Moesha
it was a popular 90s show yeah and it
was uh oh to the e to the Moesha yeah
now moisha shared the apartment with my
pit bull and she used to whip the pit
bull to eat the pit bull's food with its
hair
and then my dog used to look at me and
go
away
no so they did well together
[Laughter]
but give me all right maintain icons I
can be like Dad what the [ __ ] yeah I've
always used to come like that and then
take a couple of bites look at the pit
and go like this Bob his head and then
walk away what becomes the Moesha
so Moesha
Thanksgiving
1998. it was a great Thanksgiving for me
yeah that was an amazing thing she's on
the radiator where she likes to perch
and get the sun rays yeah right remember
we're in a studio apartment meaning
everything is in the same room I wake up
I wake up to the cries of Kelly say oh
my God but we should have pushed out the
screen moisha's on the screen
story's High
back and forth
oh like balancing on the screen
yeah like it popped out and it was like
yeah she was on the radio pushed the
window screen out and she's going back
in front oh here's the creek going hello
fresh America's number one meal kit you
know we love it babe we are both
subscribed to hellofresh we like to save
money it's cheaper than going to the
grocery store we love the meals I've
learned how to cook using this my family
uses it my friends use it I love they
got the new sweet chili tofu balls or
the spicy coconut curry stir fry which
I'm telling you you know me you know I
love sauce and thick food this is
awesome and it's October baby so they
got the fall Classics they got uh uh um
pumpkin pie
um they got
um all types of different desserts fall
desserts they got a dessert board that
you can check out
um they have a pre-portioned ingredients
they make cooking so easy I seriously
love but hello fresh if you're looking
for health if you're looking for healthy
food that's cheap and you know you can
cook with your friends cook with your
family hellofresh is the is the side for
you and I cannot believe when they give
the discount codes how how like how this
company even makes money because they
give so much stuff out for free all you
have to do is go to hellofresh.com hey
babe65 and use the code hey babe 65 for
65 off plus free shipping that's
hellofresh.com hey babe65 use the code
hey babe 65 for 65 off plus free
shipping hellofresh America's number one
meal kit babe listen to me ship station
listen oh sorry babe ship station ship
station ship station listen to me do not
wait until you're drowning in orders to
find the right shipping solution okay
I'm telling you if you're running a
business you need ship station we use it
here at the podcast pimpy says it's his
favorite thing to use other than his
cameras we ship station without ship
station our businesses is is half as
successful so whether you're starting
small or scaling up ship station makes
ship happen no more limiting your
business to one store ship station
integrates with every single platform
including Amazon
Etsy eBay Shopify Etc maximize your
sales with minimal effort that's what I
like about it Max sales minimal effort
ship station customers that um uh you
know I'm a ship station customer I know
all the podcasts pretty much you ship
station we love it we've all had success
with it if you're running the business
and you don't have ship station I
guarantee you you're making your
business harder than it should be go to
shiftstation.com and sign up with the
promo code hey babe for a free 60-day
trial that is shipstation.com
s-h-i-p-s-t-a-t-i-o-n.com promo code hey
babe
h-e-y-b-a-b-e 60 day free trial that's
two months free visit shipstation.com
click the mic from the top and type in
code hey babe ship it baby yeah she was
on the radio pushed the window screen
out and she's going back and forth oh
here's the creek going
and I catch eye contact with Moesha I'm
always says stay still she doesn't
understand me I go ankle socks dirty
wife beater walk towards the the lizard
she looks at me licks her face
keeps on walking falls out the window I
look at her surfing in the air no oh
[ __ ] you watch the Free Fall oh my God
smashes to the ground you watch the
snake surf that should be awesome
you you watched yeah
free fall of a six foot iguana 80 feet
yeah well yeah
you sorted Sal what makes this story
extraordinary I run downstairs my you
know you know I run downstairs Kelly's
looking out the window oh my God she
dead Moesha is all whites looks at me
opens her eyes and continues walking no
I swear to God wait wait wait
what color was she before the four green
she was 100 white it was beautiful it
was actually beautiful like I don't like
that and now what happened she goes back
to green yeah yeah three days later
she's got her color back I thought she
might have broke something internally
she didn't break anything she didn't
break anything she lived I mean I had a
you know Dad eventually I donated Zoo
but she um was with us for years after
that and she she it took her three
months to go back by the windowsill so
she knew yeah what eventually had she
actually died then crack
[Laughter]
she was killed that Crossfire nasty
paper cut yeah
so look at this one this snake is very
inquisitive very a very uh
it's a nice way to put it yeah so now
thank you very much wants to see who you
are and bite you look at the way the
eyes move can you see that the eyes move
side to side okay so this thing is very
confident it's a very comfortable okay
so what you're doing right now is you're
you know classic is like lizzo yeah
absolutely that's a better name for him
yeah so you're caressing its neck yeah
and I can just go right under
and we're good we're good see good just
you know just jerk that thing off yeah
but he's a big boy but even you you're
gonna take him fully out not
disrespectful respectful because I'm you
know there's also a lot going on that's
unfamiliar to the lights a lot of people
here y'all want to be respectful I'm not
going to go in and show off I definitely
want to be aware and I make a fool out
of myself right enough during my
lifetime
if this one started attacking you is it
the same thing just throw Purell at it
yeah
yeah who knew like it like in the desert
all you need is just like
[Laughter]
just running away with it because she
doesn't know I'm like
you want to hold it absolutely not yeah
there's a big boy
it's a big boy no it's not that it's
unpicked by so you gotta be respectful
this is a very I don't know how to
respect or disrespect this man yeah yeah
what's the name this is Oliver Oliver I
expect bro yeah no no no no
when you when I introduce you to a snake
and you Reveal Your anal vent that's
disrespectful
picture on the floor like that's classic
scene with like a rattlesnake and you're
sitting on the floor it's like between
your legs and you're looking right at it
like this and you're just like I respect
you please no I respect you I I think
we've had a miscommunication somewhere
somewhere along the line the lines were
crossed
oh my now how many feet is this six feet
this is as big as the Iguana yeah he's
probably like six feet long a guy with
Ian fight at in the middle of covert
this is my covert purchase previous hey
babe guess yeah
yeah it's crazy right I'm a little
tentative about driving Chris always
likes to make fun of me about that so I
had Ian drive me to Pennsylvania to pick
up the snake in the middle of course it
was a corporate purchase yo thank you to
all the uh the donations uh did you get
a discount because it was covet no it
was a mistake wearing a mask to snake
vaccinated yeah you got the Johnson
Johnson backs look at it look at the
Raptor on Sergio's like nah that's
security he wants to feel like you know
supported so he knows you I don't I
would say he definitely knows me he's a
very smart how long have you had him I
had him since covid so I was like in the
middle of over we decided to make the
purchase
put everyone life in danger from my uh
yeah this one I would feel I mean so
you've left this snake alone with your
wife and daughter and been gone for a
weekend before yeah like hey just feed
the snake what's the what's the type of
respect what's the tightest constriction
you felt anywhere on your person uh when
you when you talk like that reminds me
of cops
[Laughter]
one time I had uh him around my neck and
I was cleaning his enclosure and he was
tight and you know I lost uh like to
this day I can't see right to my left
eye
as the one time I was in front of my
family and I almost choked on a Cocoa
Puff which is a [ __ ] dumb way to die
yeah yeah oh my God
can continue
my daughter's Cocoa Puffs without you
know because that's her cereal
it was the last bowl and I'm making icon
and I was like
[Music]
my daughter was just looking at me like
that yeah somebody gets shot in front of
his building
on a fire
oh my God I can't believe the way you
behave because it's tongue in front of
thousands of strange people weekly yeah
not in front of snakes though but Sergio
but that's what the audience is Michigan
Vancouver Portland when you had it on
Michigan when you had it feel tight too
tight for your liking how did you undo
that you just did with your hands yeah
yeah and then it did it did he let go
yeah he was fine he was just you know
trying to climb it didn't feel oh so
he's a climber yeah
about reading Behavior wrong uh you go I
don't know if you guys are interested
you could pull up woman gets attacked by
a snake of reticulated python pull I
mean pull it up what are we doing what
are we what are we doing if we're not
pulling that up yes so this is the worst
case scenario this is reading this snake
wrong
she's like wait you saw it was a little
bit like I was expecting so this woman
is a Handler and made them she's a
Handler I made a mistake
no it's uh I mean let's launch them all
at the moment I don't want to not see
that one either woman gets attacked by
snake in the office that's it that's it
yeah
sir Geo can you watch his head please
Sergio what does reticulated mean again
you know what I'm not sure we should
look that up too I'm not sure that you
know every single fact about thing but
you're like what is reticulated mean
he's like I'm not I've never heard that
yeah
when you say reticulated what is what
are you implying to us well that's oh
that's the that's the name of the snake
so right but like when you say it oh my
God oh my God
that well
[Music]
as far as you jumped it did like I don't
know man it put its head under the
pillow yeah
probably is the guy like he knows
everything about sex he's talking so
he's like so knowledgeable like wearing
awe and then you asked him to read he's
like
pull this one up python
all my family all my family could name
you any gum but they can't read or write
oh yeah I know little Nims gorilla Nims
so check it out see okay
look at a fast flick in the tongue you
saw that
did you see that though oh my god dude
that's what this one's doing no slow
look how fast it is that's a food
response and she's is she like freaking
out right now she's handling it like a
champ so now what is what is the where's
the Purell this guy doesn't have Purell
right I don't know what the [ __ ] they're
doing look at this like they just pulled
the teeth off the she's in pain right
now right she's playing it cool that's a
very painful bite is it is there a
venomous she might lose she might
danger right now right she's
she's dangerous if she was alone that's
a really big that's a problem like that
could she could lose her arm kind of
thing well you know that that thing
wraps around her leg she falls down lose
you know it could be very bad
but she had a team there that didn't
really know what they were doing they're
trying to uncoil it but he got a good
grip on her
and was she and he was familiar with her
should have got alcohol they didn't
think about that they got in and I wish
we had the sound this guy probably had a
beer is she screaming oh no it's fine I
could commentate is she screaming though
is she yelling
no she's actually very calm you want to
put on the sound for yeah yeah
oh so she's still commenting to the
video at what point do you just pull out
a gun and shoot the snake in the head
would you have to do that eventually can
you pause with us now you have to do
that you could stab it I would stand now
explain stuff to you guys it's all about
the environment you see behind the what
the wooden casing yeah those are
uh cages for breeding rats so now you
have a snake who's very full motivated
in the same room as a place where rats
are being bred so this snake is
constantly like a shark in the water
like smelling blood that's part of the
reason why she was so you should never
have your rats in the same room as
you're saying have a separate room for
your rats yeah so why is she but she
looks like she's some sort of Handler or
professional why is she making bonehead
moves like that I don't know let's be
honest it's flicking its snake very fast
here Sergio
snake that's slow it's licking its
tongue sorry I want to flick that snake
out the [ __ ] window
uh I'd like to see all right now a word
from our sponsor better help I'm telling
you mental health is so prevalent in
almost every Community almost every
person I know mental health problems are
profound better help has helped me
that's why I've gotten mentally healthy
I got my family on better help I'm on
better help my dad Tampa Tony is on
better help we all use better help what
we love about it is they they link you
up with with counselors and therapists
that work for you that match you know
your personality and what you're going
through and you do it all from the
comfort of your own home you do not have
to go to an office you do it all from
the comfort of your own home it's been
awesome it's actually been life-changing
a therapist can help you become a better
Problem Solver make it easier to
accomplish your goals no matter how big
or small and right now all you have to
do is go to better help that's help.com
hey babe okay better help h e
lp.com hey babe and you're gonna get a
10 discount off your first month
betterhelp.com hey babe 10 discount off
your first month this is a really
important one guys get your Mentor
health and get your mental health and
check better help will help you thank
you better help
what's up Babes I got a brand new hour
of stand-up material I am coming to
Baltimore Maryland the Baltimore
soundstage October 27th and then
November 17th and 18th to the Royal
Theater in Toronto Canada so Toronto in
November and Baltimore in late October
chrisdcomedy.com for Ticky Wiki's babes
brand new hour you're gonna loved it go
get the tickets rocket money and burn
another thing
rocket Money Baby also known as true
bill rocket money literally okay if you
don't know what this is I use it pimp
uses it Sal use it we all use it and we
save so much money because you know
sometimes how many of us are subscribed
to something that that we don't want to
pay for anymore and we just forget about
it when the money just keeps hitting us
each month and we think oh oh only five
dollars only ten dollars but when you
handle that up sometimes you're spending
thousands of dollars a year on stuff
that you don't even use so what rocket
money does it goes in there and it owns
describes you to all these things I mean
literally if you're wasting your money
on subscriptions with 80 of people have
subscriptions they forget they forget
about maybe for you it's an unused
Amazon Prime account or a Hulu account
that never gets streamed whatever it may
be rocket money AKA true bill is going
to help you do you know how much your
subscriptions really cost do you I'm
telling you they cost a lot the app
shows all of your subscriptions in one
place and cancels what you don't want
for you rocket money can even find
subscriptions you didn't even know you
were paying for you may even find out
you've been double charged for a
subscription to cancel a subscription
all you have to do is press cancel and
Rocket money takes care of the rest I
love this cancel unnecessary
subscriptions with rocket money today go
to rocketmoney.com hey babe seriously it
can save you hundreds per year that's
rocketmoney.com slash hey babe it says
wholeheartedly change my life it's the
best app I've ever used rocket money dot
com slash hey babe
uh I'd like to see the the lady get
attacked in the hallway as well it seems
like it's it sweeps week here on the Pod
yeah
wow I see I wouldn't know what to do
there
well now we know actually I bet you I
bet you one day that Purell tip is gonna
help say it helps probably save your
life help someone at least we should
even reveal that that uh look he's got
the hook this guy's got the hook
yeah that's that's not doing anything oh
my God she's spraying blood onto the
floor that's a nasty bite the hook like
Sandman at the Apollo is it spraying
blood is it spraying blood because she
had an open wound and now it's squeezing
the blood out
I'm sure it doesn't help that well
actually it's providing its own
tourniquet right really think about it
yeah so you know I want to bite you and
then help you out real quick you know if
people show off for the camera she may
have rushed it right because there was a
camera but that's a slow flick the way
he came out I was a food motivated
response okay I would have hit him with
the the hook behind yeah and I would
have been very slow moving has he ever
come out with the snake faster you know
he wants food yeah I know when he's
hungry and he wants food every time I go
into that cage he's like I love that I'm
getting this much I'm really I'm really
genuinely coming away from this learning
things today yeah you know what I mean
I'm gonna have a conversation with my
niece now she has like a dozen these I'm
gonna impress her Bangkok Thailand here
we are this snake jumps out
why is there a loose snake these are
three women just walking down the
hallway and a snake just jumps out and
holy [ __ ] is an interesting area where
you can have City and then immense
Wildlife right like on the side of the
road you can have elephants they have
sun bears
uh which is the smallest bear they have
all sorts of like venomous reptiles and
meanwhile there's like a club right off
the block she kicked her slipper right
off
the snake was likely driven in by heavy
rain and it drew and it driven drove it
right into the sixth floor of an
apartment building in Bangkok
all right all right well
I think I've had enough of this
I don't think I can continue actually
yeah well just to add on a positive note
let's do the one where um this guy had a
a 30-foot uh Python and he throws it out
the window because there's a fire and
the woman climbs up the snake and
rescued it from the fire so let's pull
that up so that's possible
it's like the snake Rapunzel story
I do have a question yes yes yes do you
have you ever seen snake ghosts
have you seen one what I thought
people's gonna be like have you ever
seen ghosts of snakes guess about ghosts
no do you feel like they have any
personality at all
uh well they just dead inside no they
they have a yeah I would say some of
them especially these bigger ones have
personalities not much
what kind of personality it's like some
of that but it's a little more calm and
cool other ones are like a little
flighty that's what this sort of thing
like imagine bumping into like uh
you know uh you know personality in the
club that's just like
you know
[Laughter]
like we bump into somebody's like I'm
just unsure of their feelings you know
like they're just kind of like look at
this snake on the back that's up on the
back of a fiately like oh they're
engaging
yeah the snakes on the highway that's
their back [ __ ] said it was rescued by
Highway workers could you imagine you're
just working on the highway and they're
like we need you to do an animal rescue
it's a [ __ ] 35-foot snake so what he
got this person does not know that's not
that person's snake how did that happen
I have many questions who knows it's a
probably an Uber yeah have you ever done
stand up with the snakes on I feel like
I want to do that because I'm running
out of [ __ ] I've been running out of
[ __ ] for years now and maybe just have
the snake on my neck and but never
address it that's good this is this
[ __ ] do comedy and there's like a
[ __ ] you and I'm just like come on
we'll be on one of my shows
I'd love to see Chris to stand up with
the snake on oh there's a clip dude
snake on stage every time a joke misses
go she's wanting to try to do one bit
with it with us with that around your
neck one bit and what would it what
would it look it's questioning its
[ __ ] hand
very strong
do they sleep yeah with their eyes open
really my eyelids really yeah so are
they seeing in their sleep no
but they don't you don't know what this
you don't know oh right
you could you could you could test
yourself if you weren't going yeah
like teach your kids a lesson with the
snake no I don't like to use snakes that
way I just start beating somebody with a
snake yeah I was irresponsible you had
mentioned that you had a rock you had
two rottweilers I had a Rottweiler that
I bought off my mother bought off a cop
at the age of uh I was like nine years
old that thing is too close to your neck
he was um he's fine and I said my
friends came into the apartment we used
to go like that I used to go watch
used to get all riled up that's very
irresponsible this is the
money
yo make no mistake my steaks match my
kicks
wow yo so you're not you're not scared
for your cat's life in the room with all
those snakes listen man the time I left
the [ __ ] snake enclosure but thank
God it's been every other enclosure but
all of this because he could take down a
cat and he's always hungry like there's
more about like people yeah I don't have
the pet anymore but like but what about
if the pit came in contact with that I
think they'll be in different choices in
one another I think they would I don't
think the pit will bother
um but the snake may just run away from
it because like the size okay but the
cats that's a good meal for Oliver well
the snake is if that snake was on the
floor here and you walked in is the
snake scared of you
do they see you as a Potential Threat
yeah if you're hovering over them and
you're fast moving and but you know it's
where you approach them you say how he
came out was very slow moving right you
know I'm acting like I'm part of the
earth it's kind of just come on not like
and is that that's the truth with most
snakes like if you approach any snake
like that odds are they're not going to
try to bite you first if you don't smell
like right what about if you saw a snake
in the desert yeah I would you know it
depends each snake is different like I'm
talking about my domesticated right
that's the way I handle it I won't I
don't want to necessarily [ __ ] with a a
snake at a desert that could be venomous
right that could be just wrapping itself
around the microphone and at no point as
much experience as you have and as many
times as they've been on your neck and
you've done this exact scenario at no
point do you ever have a thought creep
in that second guesses yourself in the
moment you're like I just got this
heebie-jeebies a little bit nah the
dummy peonies ah okay I
I feel like that around common folk that
I interact with every day but not much
right so you feel so you feel safer
around snakes than you do around people
you know that's right now you're a
dirtbag have you ever rented this
have you ever entered this out to a
kid's party or done that no but I want
to get into that field no no in the
beginning of the pandemic he did it like
showed off all his animals from his
house on Instagram live best believe I
didn't want underwear yeah underwear on
any
dick terrified in the back
why does this phone keep freezing I'm
like he got T-Mobile
Sergio where can people find you oh
Sergio chicone.com all the social media
is dead dates with you are there and a
couple other shows and yeah and so it's
easy the website searchcon.com that's it
and if you you know can people will you
ever will you ever have like a live
appearance with your snakes out in like
Thompson Square Park or around your
neighborhood they're gonna have to pay
for that go see Sergio obviously the
funniest sweetest dude ever look at like
a sling now I can't do anything with my
arm that's how powerful he is this is my
arm resting really yeah you can't get
out of that I could get out of him I'm
gonna need you guys help
we'll see
maybe let's get to let you want to get
to you want to get to know Sergio
without the snakes yeah
put the snake in the box that's taking a
box Serge put your snake in a box can we
just put the snake on the table yeah
we're on
all right you want to put the snake down
wherever it goes It goes
is that crazy no it's not crazy I'll
just put them right here oh my God
yeah
I don't think we're unfortunately I
don't think we're gonna warm up to it in
in this amount of time you want to let
it eat like a painting of DeRosa oh can
you can you feed it
do you have reactions I don't have rats
in my back pocket although I did have a
friend growing up who used to put
chicken wings in his pocket and feed her
no and feed himself after playing
basketball oh my God sounds like
something Hillary Clinton
is he that wow yeah is he also a
pandering politician he used to wear
jogging pads and we used to play hoops
and he used to go in his pocket take
pick out the lint and eat chicken wings
and then throw him behind his head like
a banana peel like you gotta be kidding
me no I'm serious
he'd ball with the wings in his pocket
yeah and he used to stand sideways I
remember he was very like favorite the
left side of like his hip he would like
lean over and just like took her and
maintain I could be a scoliosis and you
were making fun of someone who's
disabled and and pull the lint off too
again eat the chicken that throw the
ball behind his head like a cartoon
character would throw a banana peel
right did you not do not come in with it
I don't have any more toilet paper left
bedding
yeah christycomedy.com
um question did did he know he was were
you guys laughing at it did he know he
was joking around or was he dead serious
no he was dead serious he didn't think
it was he didn't like did you guys clown
him no I I I don't know if I can't I was
I I knew enough to like make it was just
so it was it was baffled I was baffled
because we had this physically
just finished playing
basketball like if it's just always
black when you play basketball right if
you have to go Pierre wasn't a thing in
1992. so he's going in his pocket but
yet he's hygienic according to his
standards right he's gonna stick out the
lid right eating chicken
pasta rock yeah a wild grew up in the
Lower East Side like the amount of
characters he has a friend he had a
friend going up the Lower East Side that
he would like get drunk and he would
like when he would get drunk his
eyeballs would go in the back of his
head
rewind it wasn't drunk let's not let's
not let's not cocaine let's start
softening stuff
this was full-blown cocaine out of die
boys to hang out at yeah and we used to
call him slot machines because I used to
roll like he [ __ ] God are you kidding
me I was like what a great nickname
complete a substance he would go yo
Soldier man
all night like that yeah you're the man
as eyes to just [ __ ] roll growing up
in the Lower East Side like when he grew
up you know growing up right now if you
guys are familiar with New York if
you're not I'll tell you lower east side
right now is one of the most gentrified
parts of the whole city very safe you
know there's yoga students there's still
dirt bags though it's coming back but
but it is it's got its dirty it's Mayor
de Blasio it's coming making a nice
comeback now to its olden days but when
Sergio grew up there in the 90s it was
like that was like a very very difficult
neighbor to grow up in Manhattan it's
not deaf and despair now both now both
worlds are colliding where you get the
accommodating factors like a city bike
for people who want to ride to work but
you know it was on the city bikes yeah
the [ __ ] ghouls and goblins that
coverage revealed so these [ __ ] guys
who I know don't have active bank
accounts are writing these
my dad that was his that was he he
worked for the New York City Sanitation
it was his that was his hood that's
where he worked the Lord
oh early morning he must have seen
everything he's seen everything did he
tell you like a lot of stories really
yeah everything you could think of he's
seen it he's seen it all yeah I mean a
lot of people getting killed
dead people people getting killed
everything you can think of everything I
seen growing up on the Lower East Side
and this is no [ __ ] I see three
bodies pulled out of the East River
right you actively saw this yeah
a goddess thing I was just I was young
in the hobby yeah and uh if you guys
need I sent a guy shot behind us had a
neighborhood guy shooting another
neighborhood guy and I'm playing
handball against a white van and we
never stopped the game which that was
the crazy thing that's called trauma and
this is some [ __ ] that's happening so
now I'm like that's not normal wait wait
wait wait I was playing a handball
against a white van which is
unbelievable already right right and
then a neighborhood guy every day shot
another guy was seen every day behind
the head and ran away like a freaking
like a cartoon character with a bag of
money like this with a gun like behind
his head and so you you saw the man who
was shot behind the head just laying
there with his brains on the page I
didn't see Bloods and and and brains
because it was like on the corner of the
block but I saw him fall flat on his
face and he's dead right dead right
around the spot but they got away he ran
away was the most like
the hesitating thing yeah like the knees
would say it's just as hell is back like
but so you guys were laughing at this
guy wait wait wait you didn't yeah you
did you just stopped playing handball
now it makes sense that was wild to me
that that I didn't realize that the cops
came up to me and I was talking about
like I knew these cops the cops were
like what did you say I said well I saw
a guy and my friend was going like this
like shut the [ __ ] up right and I was
like I don't really see much in the
office I was like hey come on man you
said it and
yeah I stopped talking and then we
continue playing handball so so you were
eyewitness didn't know eyewitnesses said
anything right so what about when you
saw the guy that shot him later on
now you asked you too many questions
I saw the guy like 20 years later he was
buffed you know act like he didn't know
me and I was like oh [ __ ] yo that guy
just shot someone so he got away with it
to this day
he did like 20 years he did like for
that murder yeah yeah he got caught oh
he's out it wasn't my doing make that
very clear I didn't say anything I would
just say I saw a guy get shot they were
like who wasn't I wasn't a go into it
like as I was going off adrenaline like
oh yeah he lives like but my friend
called me was like you know I don't know
how much I was going to reveal but I was
definitely talking to the cop right
people my friend was like shut the [ __ ]
up right you know damn damn dude yeah
yeah wow it's crazy when you experienced
it you didn't even run no no it was just
like it was I remember that was that
that's something that I always go back
to how we just kept on with the night
when we when I I live with my
grandparents when I was growing up uh in
Staten Island and not not a great
neighborhood and um we would hear
gunshots all the time like it was
nothing like we would hear that we would
be sitting with my parents and my
grandparents didn't have air conditioned
so we'd have the windows open in the
summer right and we'd be sitting in the
living room like watching television and
he had gunshots and to the point where
we weren't even like we didn't blink
we're just like oh gunshots right yeah
it was just I mean I I don't if I would
have seen someone get shot more like in
the head in front of me I don't think I
would have continued to handball but but
we did we were like you do become a
little numb to it
wow yeah dirt back [ __ ] well it's it as
you're revealing your childhood it's
getting more and more obvious why you
feel comfortable with snakes wrapped
around your body why you think it's okay
to leave your family unintended with
venomous animals because what you're
basically saying to them is hey I saw a
guy get shot I kept playing handball you
could deal with a little rattlesnake
yeah yeah you could do illegal
reptilians
Sergio's one of those guys who's clearly
gotten better looking as he's gotten
older
[Laughter]
you know what it is I remember that
photo shoot you know yeah I remember I
was home yeah
yeah best believe well that's the thing
when you're like an actor like when
you're an ex [ __ ] drunk and and Drug
you by the way yeah the photos that
surface they're like oh [ __ ] like oh
it's been sober for 10 years right now
he's reticulated
soldiers are reticulated Puerto Rican
which by the way Antonio
avoided that question and that kept on
looking at you like I gotta look that
way I was trying to Google it yeah
you don't let Sal leave he's like yo
delete that
we're gonna need to cut that out yeah
yeah yeah also the word we invented we
couldn't remember last week someone
posted it elasticity
that's what it was
um
it has the ability to stretch no I I
think that's
[Music]
they literally cooked the steak they
they drench it in gold is the one oh God
it's so funny and then they bring it out
and they go in a suitcase you can get
such a better deal at hello fresh just
use the promo code hey babe 16. is that
did you see the one with the gold the
gold steak it was like thousands of
dollars they dipped it in gold and they
bring it out with a suitcase wait they
bring it on a suitcase and then they
have a team a SWAT Team come out with
guns and surround the suitcase and then
like it's all part of the ordering the
steak it's so douchey though
you order the steak a guy comes out in a
suit with a briefcase and he's
surrounded by a SWAT team with guns [ __ ]
they bring it to the table and the SWAT
team is surrounding the table with the
guns they open the suitcase and pull out
the stake that is dripped in Gold that's
so stupid God it's so stupid I just saw
it online
it was thousands of dollars and they
made a whole thing about it like like
I'm sure if you Googled like gold steak
suitcase SWAT team or something I mean
people just
one of those videos has a whole SWAT
team behind them
oh whatever the snake by the way it's
I'm embarrassed when they come over with
a candle and cupcake to sing Happy
Birthday me too hate it
those the nightclub with the freaking
sparklers with the bottle that's big and
then blowing whistles and walking over
I'm like oh my God please Jesus Christ
vegans putting flowers on Meats in
grocery store to honor dead animals well
that's that's one thing that's wrong
with everybody right now
we'll be a guy with a haircut like that
100
yeah here you go
well I would have told me she's a vegan
I would have never guessed laughs
what are you going to put what are you
going to lay on the on the rose for the
for the person that sniffed the rose
and kill the rose also who's funding
this that's expensive
roses are not cheap yeah
they are not cheap is this a sign of
which they're recording themselves well
it got 20 million views you know when
you think about if you really boil it
down sometimes the content is very easy
to make yeah just 20 million views on
something I mean that that got
25 of the views of the Seinfeld finale
she got sick from year five sneezes uh I
would say I would say there's a 90
chance at least somebody including the
snake is gonna have a call tomorrow yeah
we'll see what happens I'll be sending
your doctor's bill
oh my god do you take them out every
time you come home like do you spend
what when do you spend time with them do
you carve it out yeah I can't believe
you dude by your behavior you told me
that when it's looking for food the
tongue goes fast that was going very
fast
it's been hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe